assalamualaikum everyone this is
asadullah Ali of the Andalusian project
and I'm just coming at you right now
with sort of an informal video a
PostScript for ijihad episode 4 which
just came out
um the reason I'm doing this is because
I want to look at some comments and
attempted refutations or initial
refutations of episode 4 by a bunch of
ex-muslims on this popular ex-muslim
Forum on Reddit
and the reason I'm doing this is because
I really want to kind of showcase the
mentality that that I'm dealing with
here on the internet and uh to Showcase
a lot of Felicia's reasoning so that you
guys will really understand
um
you know sort of the anti-islamic fervor
and where it's coming from not only that
but you can kind of also see that a lot
of these ex-muslims really have no good
reasons for being ex-muslims
um and and I guess a further reason that
I'm doing this is because I really want
to show you guys
like just just the the ludicrous nature
of the narratives that they push
so uh Abu Ren's going to be joining me
today to look at these comments we're
going to start with the most ridiculous
ones first uh just for fun and then
we'll you know we'll look at some more
that are a little bit more rational more
coherent and address those as well
um that said this is really like I said
it's gonna be an informal video
um I'm not going to take it too
seriously but of course the arguments
the counter responses that I use will be
um will be valid in sound so don't worry
about that we will have a little bit of
fun though let's see what we got here
first
okay comment number one
from fazuz Ash root 18 points so 18
people thought this was a good comment
okay just remember that
uh that was a huge waste of time he
didn't refute anything at all in fact he
doesn't deny most things but says
something like but some other
interpretation said it differently but
you use that Hadith instead of another
Hadith but in the English translation
you used another word okay let's just
stop there real quick
um yeah no none of this happened in that
one hour video uh but some other
interpretations said it differently
actually no that's that that wasn't the
case never said that once what I did say
was I used uh the master Arab's very own
references to refute him so it wasn't
alternative interpretations or this
interpretation said it differently it
was uh the very thing that the master
was using to back his own points
refuting him
it wasn't an alternative interpretation
I don't even know where this is coming
from
but you use that Hadith instead of
another Hadith I never complained about
that in fact I consider all of the
master Arabs Hadith to be sound I have
no problem with them I do believe that
one needs to be uh you know has to use
various how do you get the full
understanding of what's going on but I
never said I never complained about him
using Hadith next he said but in the
English translation it uses another word
null never even said that not once nope
didn't even make any sort of argument
even even close to that so I I have no
idea what this guy is watching because I
mean that wasn't even my video
uh and then this gets really funny
he goes on he goes and then like every
other Muslim accuses him of being fake
or some Jew in disguise
are you serious
I don't think I even mentioned once in
that video that the master was somehow
fake or a Jew
I don't even consider Jew to be an
insult are you are you serious no I did
call the master of a coward because it
was very obvious that you know he lacks
integrity and and that he's very
dishonest I also call him dishonest but
my none of those ever happened funny
being accused of being a Jew by
abrahamic lunatics uh funny being
accused of accusing people of being a
Jew by someone who claims to be rational
anyways let's move on to the next one I
don't I seriously don't know what's
wrong with this guy okay next one
National Marxist oh this is going to be
good
he's a joke he doesn't refute anything
and then one of the more rational
ex-muslims jumps in I don't know man
everything he said checks out good job
man good job you know the truth
even though you're an ex-muslim you know
I was being right you know I had
presented valid in sound arguments you
know that I you know I uh showed
evidence from my position so obviously
there's no funny business going on here
then the response is hilarious it
doesn't prove Allah's existence now does
it
done
are you are you joking talk about a red
herring just flying out of nowhere I
mean this is this is like a red herring
Like You Dropped a Bomb from from like
Mars I mean are you serious like that
far of left field
the whole the point of the whole video
wasn't even to prove Allah's existence
it was to refute claims that Islam
supports terrorism
I mean
where I don't even I don't even know
what to say here
how ludicrous can you be I mean I have
no idea what to say to this it is that
stupid
um
okay let's let's move on to another one
because I just I can't fathom
you know the ignorance here
oh this one is great by not a throwaway
three four five
really not a throwaway well sorry to
break it to you son but uh you're about
to get thrown away here okay one entire
hour to refute the masked Arab LOL
really seriously this is this is the
problem here with a lot of these
so-called rationalists
these so-called free thinkers
they can't stand it when something is
too too lengthy they think it's some
somehow like invalidates the arguments
being used
um although you know they'll post for
hours on Reddit or Facebook or Twitter
you know trying to refute people and you
know they'll watch The Masked Arabs
series on Isis and Islam for like an
hour because you know if you combine all
those videos together it's roughly over
an hour or so but you know when somebody
refutes them oh no it's too long now
it's just it's just it's evidence of
intellectual laziness to be honest uh
yeah one entire hour to refute you know
why because there's a lot of nonsense in
those 20 minutes of videos that I
critiqued
um sorry to break it to you I apologize
one hour goodness me I I'm really sorry
it hurts your brain cells I know you
probably you can't think beyond the meme
right
um no wonder All Right Moving On
uh by Mana horlax
is it oh it's man a who relax is that
what it is I don't know either way you
can read it you know sorry you probably
shouldn't use that name that's not good
okay so let's look at this all this
tells me is that the most qualified
Scholars and their commentaries
contradict each other I guess no one can
understand the Quran
semi sad face oh goodness mate really is
that where you got is this really what
you got from this really
is that is that how desperate you are
that this is all you got from it instead
of the fact that the master Arab uh
someone who a lot of ex-muslims look up
to and even islamophobes look up to
uh the fact that he was completely
disingenuous that's not the biggest
problem here
um no a lot of people can understand the
Quran there are many meanings behind
certain passages but many people can
understand the Quran there's there's a
vast consensus on on many particular
interpretations it just when it comes to
Fick you know uh Islamic law there are
certain nuances involved that said the
idea that you know oh you know Scholars
they disagree therefore nobody can
understand the Quran that's extremely
and utterly fallacious
uh no it just means that there are
various opinions uh doesn't mean that
all opinions are absolutely valid and
sound it doesn't mean that everyone is
right you know there can be people who
are wrong and people who are right you
know it happens okay in every field
um in every uh religion every ideology
every political ideology every moral
ideology you know every economic
ideology every ideology you can think of
there are various interpretations of
what those ideologies teach and and how
to interpret certain texts from the
founding fathers of those ideologies Etc
you know there are not just one
interpretation of democracy you know but
no you don't see people complaining
about that you know there's not one
interpretation of particular moral codes
or or meta-ethical theories you know
people some people are utilitarian some
people are pragmatic some people hold to
Virtue ethics Etc
you know they're not saying now oh you
know that means that morality doesn't
exist because people have different
opinions on it you know or there's not
one you know uh right moral code like
nobody says that and the people who
they're all actually there are people
who say that but they're stupid uh and
they're typically post-modernist
you know you can't have the fact that
you have an opinion on morality
showcases that you believe that there
are certain certain Truths Behind that
in the same way you can say about
religion just because people have
different interpretations does not
necessitate that people can't understand
or that there is no understanding of
behind the Quran now maybe he didn't say
that maybe he didn't for all this but
this is typically why these sort of
responses are made and it's really
intellectually lazy and quite pathetic
to be honest
um
you know and at the same time when
they're attacking Islam then all of a
sudden oh they have the true
understanding there you know
so let's move on to another comment okay
next by Saturn nine okay Southern nine
eh some of the master herbs claims were
had some fishy
English need to learn okay
um
yeah well at least he admits that that
there is something wrong with the master
Arabs views even though he only says
some when it's like most of them but
anyways
he goes on but it doesn't change the
fact that the Quran has verses directed
for violence and the popular Narrative
of Islamic history was violent
oh really okay uh who cares if it
doesn't change the fact that the Quran
has verses directed for violence of
course the Quran has verses directed for
violence it's called reality bro
um I don't know if like if you've like
looked if you've like stepped outside of
your home but yeah of course the Quran
has verses directed for violence because
there are going to be violent people in
the world a religious text that doesn't
have verses directed for violence is not
really a religious text that deals with
reality
I I really don't ever understand this
like it's I feel like a lot of
ex-muslims play this pacifist card oh
yeah we're all a bunch of pacifist you
know we're angels and we we're you know
we will never hurt a soul we will never
step on a bug you know it's like really
are you serious
and you know I think they only play this
card when they're attacking Islam but
you know when it comes to everything
else oh no no no no no just war is
perfectly fine as long as the Muslims
don't do it nudge nudge you know this is
really what it is it's pathetic I really
cannot believe oh oh my God the Quran
talks about war oh no it's violent man
up
you know get you know a thicker skin
okay the world is not you know roses and
daisies okay you have to fight sometimes
to survive to you know stand up for
things to protect people you love okay I
don't understand that this is so
ridiculous uh continuing on and the
popular Narrative of Islamic history was
violent what does that even mean yeah it
was violent you know there were a lot of
wars in Islamic history and most of them
were primarily defensive and you know
this because if you know history which
many explosives don't because
I have no idea why I think most people
don't really know much about history and
they don't really care because I think
science is like the only thing you need
to understand in order to to comprehend
the world around you yeah we need to
learn biology to learn about politics
um people are ignorant of History
and um if you knew anything about this
period of time or even prior to the past
100 years okay you would know that every
civilization was an Empire and what does
that mean well let me give you some
Clues
uh
what do you think the Byzantine Empire
and the Persian Empire were doing prior
to the Muslims where do you think they
got all that territory from do you what
what selling Girl Scout cookies I mean
what were they doing I asking people to
give up their land or were they
violently conquering everyone around
them this is what the Muslims had to
deal with when they finally became a
stable unified Society they looked
around and they were surrounded by two
empires who were more than willing to
conquer them when they felt like it at
the time they were fighting each other
so it really wasn't
you know on their list of things to do
but they were very much interested in
conquering Arabia when the time came so
this idea that somehow oh the Muslims
just like randomly one day decide let's
go kill some infidels like no that's not
how it worked okay
um a very different world back then a
war was the default I mean if you sign a
peace treaty then you know then you
would be insured of your safety but you
know prior to that basically you would
already know that you're at war with
this person because those Empires were
ready to fight you and take your land
and you had to be prepared to fight them
or you know you're basically going to be
wiped off the face of the Earth
it's like and the fact that you know
this is such Common Sense thing if you
just read history it's not even like
it's not even controversial it's not
even apologetics it's Common Sense fact
and the fact that I have to continuously
repeat this to individuals who are
you know incessantly telling everyone
else how rational and knowledgeable they
are it's just it just I want to hit my
head against a brick wall okay
oh my God next
grappling with truth
actually he's a decent guy
um but he still has he still says some
things here that I don't really agree
with so let's get through this
a worthy rebuttal by an intelligent
person that still falls short well thank
you very much it is a worthy rebuttal
and I appreciate you calling me
intelligent however I don't understand
why you think it's fall short let's see
what you say
this does not explain why Allah sent a
book that can be so easily
misinterpreted many other deeper issues
have yet to be addressed
uh really
I hear this a lot
um about how everything can be so easily
misinterpreted how a Divine text has to
be some sort of like
um like when it comes down not only does
it have to be clear but everyone has to
agree with it in the same way regardless
of whether or not they're free thinking
regardless of whether or not they have
certain desires Etc what I mean to say
is it doesn't this sort of rebuttal does
not take into account that people have
different levels of understanding
that some people just don't want to
understand literally I mean there are
people out there who really honestly do
not care to understand
uh looking at some of the previous
comments and some of the future comments
you'll you'll notice that
um some people are just more obsessed
with their desires than anything else
and you know people's stupidity somehow
doesn't play a part in this look you can
make the clearest argument the most
logically valid the most logically sound
argument in existence okay and there
will still be people out there no matter
what who will refuse to accept it for
various reasons whether it be cognitive
dissonance or some sort of Desire they
have or you know wanting to stick with
their Traditions their family or some
sort of loyalty you know this is a human
trait for people to deny facts okay
there's a reason that flat earthers
exist all right and it's not because you
know uh the fact that the Earth is round
is somehow a difficult concept to
understand okay it's not all right a
child can understand it but for some
reason there are people out there who
are so skeptical of the scientific
consensus that they literally believe in
the Flat Earth okay
now you can say well you know but it's a
Divine text Divine text means that
everyone needs to understand Allah needs
to force it onto everyone's head Free
Will what is that you know this is such
I'm sorry this is such an intellectual
laser response because as far as I'm
concerned it like I said it doesn't take
into account people's Free Will people's
levels of understanding people wanting
to understand or not it blames
everything on the text itself now is it
possible that a text can be badly
written and be so vague that it can't be
understood yes but I mean come on this
is not even this is I mean even in the
video it wasn't even difficult for God's
sake I just had to quote like when I
went to the masked Arabs references it
was like a couple of pages apart it was
not difficult to understand
I I mean are you serious is this really
hard for you is it so difficult to
understand what the Quran says for you I
mean is it really
or are you making it difficult
I I don't I don't get it it's like the
easiest book I have ever read I'm sorry
to say I mean yeah it's complex
but complexity does not necessitate
difficulty okay I mean it is so easy to
read it's so easy to understand it's not
like you look at it and go oh my God
what's going on like no that's not what
happens
okay
now is it possible that you might have
various interpretations in your mind and
you want to kind of yeah but the once
you when you look at the Quran
holistically and you look at the
commentaries and you look at the Hadith
and so it's not difficult it literally
takes me like five minutes to look up
some of these interpretations it's not
even hard
why is this
why is this even a rebuttal
this does not explain why Allah sent a
book that can be so easily
misinterpreted
is it so easily misinterpreted because
it's badly written or that because it's
not clear or is it so easily
misinterpreted because people generally
want to be stupid
and I'm saying that frankly because it
seems to me that they do
it seems to me nowadays especially
people only want to understand like a
meme you know they want they don't want
anything beyond a meme if it's not
presented in a meme format it's not
worthy of consideration
um yeah I I don't I don't take this uh I
have no respect for this sort of
rebuttal
um it just makes no sense to me
um I am not a genius I am not a genius
so if I can do if I can understand these
things so easily what's stopping you I
mean really
if you're I mean you guys apparently a
lot of you are ex you know a lot of you
ex-muslims are atheists so I apparently
you're the most intelligent people on
the planet so why are you having such a
hard time
I don't get it
uh let's move on to what I consider to
be the more coherent responses here
I think there's some more ridiculous
ones too but let's just look at these
first
hijaz hermit interesting
okay well this is not actually not a
very intelligent response uh but let's
just look at it anyway I'm just gonna
call it the guy who narrates the
Andalusian project will be a future X
Muslim by 2025. oh crystal ball
awesome I thought you guys didn't
believe in magic
all right he goes on to say you can't
have a you can't have structured
arguments without eventually
experiencing cognitive dissonance
really
uh that doesn't make any sense bro
um
having a structured argument means that
you think more coherently so you
shouldn't have cognitive dissonance
right now I can understand if you had
like structured arguments over here and
then you kind of like believed a lot of
irrational stuff over here but if I'm
consistent with structured arguments uh
yeah no cognitive dissonance there bro
he's very well spoken naturally uh
because I'm educated
yeah
you know I I worked for that you know I
didn't just like wake up one day and go
hey I lack belief in God therefore I'm
intelligent you know I actually went to
University you know I read a lot things
like this
seems to Value Integrity yep that's the
academic standard and claims to dislike
mental gymnastics uh actually I hate
that term in and of itself I hate that
phrase I think it's ridiculous uh mental
gymnastics it just to me that just
sounds like
it's too complex for me to understand
therefore you must be you know doing
something wrong that's basically what it
what it translates to me I mean I
understand how it's being used for like
overly convoluted like
post-hoc rationalizations but
it just it gets thrown around all the
time like mental gymnastics is
everything that I disagree with
basically that's what it's been used for
uh so you know a lot of you out there
who want to use the term mental
gymnastics for people like me who like
to use facts and logic well then you
know great I'm glad that I'm committing
mental gymnastics because at least one
of us is doing something with our brain
anyways Moving on but he simply doesn't
have the arguments on his side oh really
can you point that out I'd love to see
it
and for a meticulous person like him I
know it slightly tugs at his soul it
tugged on my soul too oh big group hug
yeah don't flatter yourself
oh he goes on I would assume he's in his
early 20s nope 32 but thanks I
appreciate that Muslim convert seem to
take a bit longer oh
they are exposed to an egalitarian
version of Islam in the west which can
be truly beautiful and in some respects
Superior to Christianity but it's not
the legitimate Islam of the Prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam unfortunately
it may take another Islamic State for
him to truly appreciate his potential oh
yeah I need the Islamic State to tell me
how awesome I am okay
ah yeah I know what you're saying here
but it's just ridiculous um
first off I wasn't exposed to that I've
always been exposed to a very balanced
form of Islam
and uh
the Islamic State didn't even shake my
faith at all because I already read
about these types A long time ago you
know
um so I I really I mean it didn't even
bother me in the least I expected them
to come I expected them to come a long
time ago and I expected them to come
right after the fact that Iraq was
bombed into Oblivion uh because they
usually come about in times of like
fitna times of instability
uh and you know when you shake a
person's Faith to the extent of bombing
their country into Oblivion killing
their family members and destabilizing
their society you can't be
how should I say surprised that some of
them take more extreme interpretations
he goes on to say on a similar subject I
love Hamza Yusuf and I think he's
starting to get tired he's updating his
web page less and less
oh my god dude you worse yeah you're so
pretentious
even more than me and that's saying
something and he's starting to make the
same statements of equivocation I did
when I was losing steam I'm not saying
I'm stronger or Superior than these guys
actually you are I just seem some
familiar events yeah except you're
trying to tell everyone that people like
me and Hamza Yusuf who are vastly more
educated than you
um and probably even more rational than
you
are somehow going to come down to your
level yeah and by the way the reason I'm
being pretentious right now is because I
can't believe how pretentious this this
comment is
yeah good luck bro uh by 2025 send me a
note and ask me how I'm doing okay and
I'll send one back to you and tell you
I'm doing just fine and I hope the uh
caliphate comes back pretty soon I'm not
talking about Isis I'm talking about the
real one
all right moving on oh he says something
else he does hermit
uh when he was asked whether there was
something he disagreed with in the video
uh he does try to give an argument here
he says if I had to summarize this video
in one sentence it would be meticulous
but lacking a clear thesis essentially
he is defending every alternative
explanation about Islam without
confronting the easier arguments
what are you talking about
I haven't defended any alternative
explanation I simply showed what the
master Arabs own sources said on the
matter that's it
that is it I didn't bring in something
you know alien into the discussion
I just use Imam and I just showed what
they thought themselves on the subject
that's it just to show how disingenuous
he was being it wasn't anything
alternative about it I mean I don't even
know where this argument is coming from
and even when he does examine Tufts here
further than the mass Arab he doesn't
appreciate the general tone of the tough
Seer that supposedly favors his
interpretation for example he will
briskly read over an entire line
absolutely dehumanizing disbelievers but
then he just focuses on the Army part to
make the weaker argument that Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam was simply
fighting a battle against aggressors uh
yet no
um no I'm not actually because
those uh verses don't even dehumanize
disbelievers just as I point out with
the verses in sort of 60. those weren't
dehumanizing anyone I mean what are you
talking about look I'm gonna be very
open and honest about these things I
have no reason to hide it yeah I focus
on the Army part because that's what the
verse says that's what the commentary
says on the matter it doesn't say oh
random non-muslims walking around
minding their own business no it's
talking about armies so what one of my
briskly reading over here or you just
don't like the fact that uh IBN kathir
and Imam Cordova said things differently
than what you interpreted I know this
strategy because I used to do it all the
time well you know stop projecting your
cognitive dissonance on me because
that's not what's going on here
um in fact I did it in a much more
pathetic way and you're still doing it
apparently logic is like any weapon you
can use it to defend anything but
without substance it goes almost nowhere
oh wow once again projection this whole
comment is without substance
all right moving on oh this is actually
probably his best
um refutation so let's get through this
his strong points mainly come during the
end and they're mostly on the
interpretation of a few Islamic battles
for example he offers a decent cultural
explanation for the military punishment
a decent now that's that is the
explanation it's not a decent one it
just is
uh I have a similar unpopular point
about not judging Muhammad sorry some
supposedly pedophilia with Aisha
stuff for the law well I'm not going to
talk about your opinion on
on this issue but so let's just move on
because actually I have an article
coming out about that pretty soon on
yakin Institute
so he goes on to say but ultimately
Assad doesn't provide enough evidence to
refute the strong thesis that Muhammad
was some thought battles primarily based
on disbelief
really
um I don't see how I didn't offer enough
evidence
um
because if you can't kill like the
majority of people like women children
monks uh you know Farmers laborers Etc
people with treaties
because of their disbelief then what
makes you think that disbelief is
generally the reason why people are
killed and fought
um you're taking a very absolute
understanding of that when the whole
Quran and even the thick itself shows
that there are so many exceptions that
that simply is not the case
um other passengers would say yes we
need to fight to get rid of disbelief
yes there are
but that does not necessitate that every
disbeliever is targeted and destroyed as
a result of that which is what I was
refuting in this video
um so I I don't really know what he's
trying to say here uh he says almost
every quranic conjunction is explained
better when you appreciate this reason
no no not really because then you just
completely wipe out all the commentary
that shows all the nuances
um and you wipe out all the thick that
makes exceptions you know for people who
shouldn't be killed
you know if you just say oh every
disbeliever is killed because of
disbelief then you've just completely
destroyed what Islam actually says on
the matter so no it doesn't no nothing
is explained better when you appreciate
this reason
um in fact it just simplifies everything
to the extent where it makes it Dumber I
mean I mean what are you talking about
this is why the ulama have such a
difficult time refuting the goal of Isis
in creating a caliphate that's because
the ulama don't want to refute Isis
regarding the caliphate because there's
that's a there's no reason to do so the
caliphate is not like some bad thing in
and of itself
just because Isis you know goes around
claiming a caliphate doesn't mean
anything
I mean it's part of every Orthodox
Muslims you know Faith to believe in
that not to say that if you don't that
you're necessarily like not a Muslim but
you know it's one of the essential
aspects of of Islam is to have this
structure
he goes on at best they merely disagree
with some of their harsh practices
merely
that's an understatement
and I have a feeling Assad internally
realizes this issue no uh no
no not at all doesn't bother me in the
least
for example if you fast forward to 2703
you'll notice how he skips reading the
three offenses that allow the killing of
a Muslim hint one of them is becoming an
apostate yeah I did that on purpose not
to hide it not even to be disingenuous
but because it was irrelevant to my
objection at the time and do you know
what that objection was you see if you
actually heard what the master Arab said
prior to that objection you would
understand why I did that because the
master air was claiming that the Quran
and the commentaries do not have any
prohibition for killing a non-muslim
so the point of me citing that that uh
that part of the commentary was just to
show that both Muslim and non-muslims
were were prohibited to be killed for no
good reason
that was it uh me adding you know the
fact that Muslims can be killed because
of Xena and stuff that that makes that
doesn't that's irrelevant to the
objection
so why would I even put that there
I mean even this is nonsense
he goes on unlike Assad's dismissal of
the master herbs Integrity I'm not going
to be that rough on him for this
omission you shouldn't be because uh I
wasn't twisting and manipulating the
sources
to make it sound like something that it
wasn't
I just left it out because it was
irrelevant
to that particular objection the fact
that you would even oh my God
the fact that you wouldn't think that
what I did and what the master Arab did
is the same is this utterly ludicrous
um he literally had a completely
opposing opinion to the very
commentaries that he was using to back
his opinion that has that is not even
close
to me leaving out that part because it
was irrelevant do you even know what
you're saying do you even know what
you're writing do you even is English
like
an actual language that you know how to
use or I mean if it isn't then you know
we can excuse this
because you know then I'll understand
you know there's a reasonable
explanation as to why you're not getting
this but it it seems to me you can write
decently well
I can't really understand why you think
that this is somehow the same
uh perhaps when he can no longer repress
it he'll state that Muhammad really
disliked treason but had no real issue
with apostasy itself
oh God repress what bro projection again
been there done that yeah you've been a
lot of places apparently
um and none of them are stable none of
them in a stable thinking place
um
I trade pretty much everything because
anything was better than accepting the
simpler explanation
what's ironic is that you're giving an
even more complex explanation than I was
good job
um
sometimes it takes a group like Isis to
slam the Quran in your face and force
you to read the book for what it is or
maybe an education is required to
understand it you know instead of you
know looking on Twitter and Reddit all
day and reading memes you know maybe not
being an intellectually lazy peasant is
is a better way of going about it you
know you know Isis has nothing to do
with it I promise
all right let's move on
oh Neil Marxism is evil oh God oh God I
can't stand this guy and there's a
reason why you'll find out in a second
five minutes in and they and they die
five minutes in and they guy is already
making semantic arguments I don't feel
like watching an hour of this and you
expect people to read your nonsense you
can't stand five minutes of something
and you want people to read what you
write
okay so it goes on oh sure terrorism is
a much more modern word than a fear
within fear or Terror who cares that's
an appeal to irrelevance what do you do
you even know what you're saying appeal
to irrelevance appeal to irrelevance
like are you trying to sound smart
because that's not what's going on here
buddy
um
yeah who cares let me tell you why
um you should care because when you're
trying to say that because the Quran
says Terror therefore it refers to an
18th century definition
um
that's a problem okay uh that's a big
problem
uh fact is that the tactic of winning a
conflict by inspiring fear terrorism in
an enemy has been known at least since
Headhunters or other Stone Age people
blah blah blah blah yes I know that
that's why I mentioned it in the video
itself but you didn't go past five
minutes so you didn't catch that
explanation because you're too
intellectually lazy to care
I mean and it's very obvious here that
because you can't look past five minutes
of a video which by the way wasn't even
where my argument started it started
later than that like in the seventh
minute or even the tenth minute
I I you know the fact that I was
mentioning the definition of terrorism I
had you know that
that wasn't even the full argument it
was just the beginning my God
tell me if I'm wrong but I suspect the
rest of this video is going to be based
on semantic arguments you're wrong
and I will probably ignore the process
of going from toaster to Fick which is
where the situational specifics get
thrown out in situations are
regeneralized such as when going from
finding a specific battle
this is where he tries to sound smart by
throwing in a bunch of terms that he
doesn't understand good job all right
edit there was also no such thing as a
civilian at the time Muhammad sorry some
so a concept like terrorism against
civilians doesn't apply well then that
means that the entire series of the
master Arab according to you is false
because if you are going to admit that
no such thing as a civilian existed back
then then you're also undermining the
master Arabs argument
there you go thanks for doing my job for
me I appreciate it
normalcy lost
quality video thank you contrary to what
I admittedly expected what are you
expecting what Dirka durka Muhammad
Jihad
get higher expectations bro
not all of us live in caves and have
AK-47s okay
some of us are actually quite educated I
know that blows your mind but trust me
on the specific points that he mentioned
though at least it appears that there is
enough scholarly weight in the direction
he favors obviously
that being said it's worrying that many
of these proclamations are in there to
begin with often with minimal context
like the I have been commanded to fight
the people Hadith
it's very easy for me to see how others
interpret that as a called for offensive
violence uh really maybe because uh
people don't understand English or
Arabic
I don't know
um nobody in the history of mankind I
think has used the people as a reference
to every single person on planet Earth
it's always been a very specific uh
statement in context to a particular
group of people like if you say the
people most people ask you in return the
people of what the people of Africa the
people of Egypt the people of Asia the
people of
you know the people of America the
people of you know you know Turkey the
people of you know various countries and
continents you know if you want to say
all of people in humanity maybe you
could say the people of Earth but you
always have to put some sort of
descriptive you know a qualification at
the end
saying the people always refers back to
a specific group of individuals that you
always have to ask well who who is the
people so if anybody's looking at this
Hadith and going oh it says the people
therefore I have to fight every human
being on planet Earth then there are
obviously
um just very dumb
it's not even a minimal context
all you have to do is like read the
history
read the other Hadith that are there
that specify it why is this so difficult
I still don't get it why is it so
difficult for a bunch of people who
claim to be so rational why if you are
all so much smarter than me so much more
you know intelligent so you know I have
higher IQs because a lot of you out
there that's how you think you think
because you know by virtue being an
atheist and somehow you've been granted
magical powers of intellect
why is this so much more difficult why
do I look at these arguments and I go
why oh my God I can't believe how dumb
this is
why
really
I mean it's just insane
okay well I think those are all the
nonsense comments that I found I'm sure
there are more but uh those are the ones
that I really want to have time for
because I'm just I'm I think I lost a
couple of brain cells reading those
really to be honest
um so I just want to thank everyone once
again for supporting the video it's
gotten a really positive response a lot
of great feedback
um I really tried to up the production
quality on this one so I'm hoping that
you guys all liked it
um and I you know I want to thank my my
supporters on patreon and PayPal as well
uh for those of you who want to see more
content uh increase quality content and
you know me to have more time to do this
content please you know support my
patreon and my PayPal and
um you can find the links in the info
box for that uh you can also find the
link in the info box for the Reddit
thread if you want to just read all this
nonsense but
God help you
um yeah that's it thank you guys again